My next guest is the esteemed
president of Voice of the Cop. He's also
an advisory member on the board of
Scion, worldwide organization uh that is
dedicated to freedom of speech, freedom
of conscience, and equality of rights
before the law. Ashra Famala is the
president of Voice of the Cops and he's
going to speak to us about the uh
persecution, religious persecution of
minorities under the Sharia specifically
specifically Copa Christians. Ashraf
Mala, a man that I long admire and I am
um honored to call him my colleague,
president of Voice of the Cops and Scion
board member. Ashraf
[Applause]
There's no amplifier.
Thank you very much to be here. I would
like to tell you I am a hater because I
am explaining to you guys what's
happening in Egypt and I don't care if
anybody call me a hater because I am
saying the truth. 1,400 years cups of
Egypt is suffering from people like that
person Ahmed Habib with their lives. We
are tired of this. What happening every
day in Egypt attacking churches,
attacking girls, kidnapping girls,
raping girls. They try to clean Middle
East from Christian and Jews. And here
you guys in America, you are sleeping.
They coming here. They already here and
what's happening in Egypt right now,
we'll have it in America soon so that
you could imagine if we don't start to
defend our freedom of speech and our
freedom of religion. I am here to ask
your help. I came to this country
because I believe in freedom of religion
and freedom of speech and you guys
trying to take this away from me. If you
are not standing up, if you are not
putting your foot in the ground and
fight for it, all of us going to lose
our freedom of speech. Don't believe
anyone saying to you Islam is a peace
religion. It is a lie. It start with
George Bush. I had a lot of admiration
for him, but once he said this word, he
was a big liar. Not because he he's a
liar, but because somebody else tell him
to say that and he was naive enough to
say it. I don't want anyone of you
became a naive person.
Read the books. Read the right books,
not the books written by people to give
you the poison and the honey. Be careful
because all whatever written inside the
Quran is killing the unbelievers.
every there is 75%
hate and against anybody else that is
not believing in Christianity. For the
first time in in my age in 100 years
they attacked the c the cathedral of
Egypt in Cairo. There was a war motto of
and machine guns and people throwing
throwing stone against the church
against people. People was gathered
there just to pray for dead people that
they were they were killed by Muslim a
few days ago three days before they were
killed there. So I am begging you to
stand up and defend your constitution.
Your constitution need you because if
you giving this if you're giving your
rights, you're going to lose your
constitution. Thank you for coming here.
God bless America. God bless all of you
guys.
Thank you.
I don't know if you understand just how
critical it is for Coptic Christians
living under the Sharia in Egypt.
Christians, Jews, Zarastrians, Buddhists
cannot be silent. We cannot we cannot
allow what's going on. And we and we
must call the Obama administration to
task for not only the abandonment of
religious minorities, but when it got so
bad for religious minorities under the
Sharia, what did Obama do? Obama State
Department merely removed that section
from the annual report. As if if a tree
falls in the forest, I guess it doesn't
make a noise. I mean, it's outrageous
that that's what they would do. That you
would eliminate the reporting on
religious minorities because it got so
bad. We see that with the DoD and the
and the green on blue attacks that they
reclassify them as something else where
you know uh we had a soldier who was
giving candy and toys to children in
Afghanistan and they killed him while he
was giving the candy out and the toys
out and that was not classified as a
green onlue attack. If that's not a
green on blue attack, then what